I moved to LA about nine years ago nine
and a half years ago took me a while to
adapt myself to the city you know I
found it kind of incredibly transfixing
and romantic this idea that la is just
unlike any other city that it has rhythm
of its own but it is full of all these
dreamers from all over the world kind of
descending on the city you know often to
make art you know to make movies or make
music it's actually kind of beautiful
and poetic you know to think about the
Dream Factory is it still exists today
and to think about that kind of balance
between dreams and reality that all the
residents of La have to kind of engage
in so that felt like fodder for a movie
and especially fodder for a musical
think of musicals as sort of event
movies these days it's all about how do
you convince people to go to a movie
Peter how do you convince them to not
wait to watch something on streaming or
on their computers musicals have really
thrived as a big screen big audience
experience where people get together in
a theater experience the numbers
experience the ups and downs of the
storytelling there's something about it
that obviously harkens back to live
theater and that I think feels like a
very kind of collective ride that we can
all go on together the idea of an imax
presentation sort of the best that
feeders can offer today and doing it in
such a way that you're you're getting
something distinctly different from what
you can get at home I just think it's
very much in keeping with the whole
philosophy an idea and said I couldn't
move you know the movie that really was
designed to be a big screen
entertainment at realizing musicals are
all about emotion I wanted this movie to
be kinetic and fun and joyful and
vibrant and heartbreaking and inspiring
and all the kind of things that you sort
of hope for from from an emotional
experience I really think musicals still
have that power you know and I wanted to
make a case for the genre as still as
vibrant and alive as ever
you